well let's get more analysis from
retired Air Vice Marshall Sean Bell Sean
um thanks a lot for talking to us this
morning let's talk about several Donetsk
and what's happening there I mean is the
city's fate sealed has it Fallen well I
think um let's look at the slightly
bigger pictures of this which is the
Russian Advance at the moment has been
much more clinical much more focused uh
much more coordinated it feels much more
like a military operation now than the
earlier phases which seem to have a lot
of political meddling in them
um and it's pretty clear the strategy
now is to take the luhansk region then
take the donets region and do it in
bite-sized portions along the way we've
seen that the Russians have taken Lyman
off to the side there that is
strategically important because it's got
some rail networks through there and
there's also some bridges across the
river which will be important for the
next phase the operation and also not
shown here but pop Asner they've also
here we go pop Asner they've taken
popasna there as well and if you and
therefore what they they're actually
gradually Titan The Noose on several
donets here and of course that region
represents only about five percent
that's left in Ukrainian hands of the
luhans oblast so that creates a real
problem for the severeign soldiers do
you stay in fight
um in the past the Ukraine is approved
particularly resilient in the urban
battle and holding if you remember not
just Mario Paul but Kiev or whatever the
trouble is once you are surrounded you
may last for a while but the outcome is
pretty bleak so that's one outcome or
you withdraw your forces ready to fight
another day and as a military guy there
are some bigger battles probably to come
I would be looking to try to withdraw
those forces which looks likely is
what's happening the Russians though are
making slow progress it's incredibly
costly it's brutal it's almost medieval
in the way that they're conducted here
laying waste to cities laying waste to
communities and a huge cost of people
along the way okay so what do the
ukrainians need to do now if they want
to win this war well Wars are all about
um maintain the initiative you want to
maintain the initiative and you want to
deny your enemy the chance to dig hate
how you work and the problem with the
Ukrainian Approach at the moment is they
are staying in cities which is great the
danger is they're getting fixed that
makes them predictable and that means
that they lose the initiative so part of
that is that they need to have some
heavier weapons as well what do I mean
by heavy weapons not manned portable
weapons because at the moment the
ukrainians can fight the close battle
pretty effectively with their guns and
anti-tank weapons but the Russians are
just feeding that fight and somehow
you've got to get into the deep battle
you've got to start targeting the
resupply lines targeting the Russian
bridges that they're using to get this
stuff into otherwise it looks pretty
bleak so part of that is they do have
some heavy weapons the the West is
providing some artillery and talked
about mlrs that is on its way
um but of course inevitably it takes a
while to get everybody trained on it
you've got to get all the ammunition in
as well so there's a time it takes to
get them in
um more recently they've talked about
Mrs now that range of that I'm like
artillery it's about 20 miles mlrs is
about 300 miles and of course the West
starts to get nervous with those sorts
of weapons about whether they actually
might be used to start targeting into
Russia itself which would be an
escalation which at the moment the West
is obviously very reluctant to get to
get involved with but let's be clear
this is a long battle we're going to see
Ebbs and flows in the progress between
the Russians and the ukrainians but at
this stage at the moment it's pretty
clear the Russians do have some momentum